from the man that brought you Fear
Factory comes an experience that's
making spirits bright and not fearful
not scary okay Santa's experience is
back at Tivoli Village even bigger than
ever who better to check it out than
Candace Charles hello and good morning
look at that behind you wow
good morning YouTube good morning folks
you guys know I love the holidays so I'm
feeling all the Vibes this morning if
you ever wanted the chance to see what
the North Pole is like well here's your
chance it's kind of perfect because
you'll get to see the man himself Santa
at the very end of this experience and
I'm joined by the great mind behind it
dirkhagen thank you so much for joining
us this morning you always have a story
you always have some creative idea for
all of this tell us a story behind it
well we did this last year for the first
time and it's really basically a social
media pop-up that's celebrating
Christmas in the whole holiday season so
we wanted to create a lot of fun
interactive photo op experiences where
the whole family can come and enjoy it
and this is sponsored by stride
education so if you have kids between
the ages of 8 and 18 you can come down
here sign them up and they actually get
to go through the experience for free
that is a big deal because I know people
are trying to get their kids out for the
holidays it can get expensive there's a
lot to see but this is a little bit
different I know this is a little bit
new this year as well what's new well we
have about three times the square
footage uh and we've added a lot more
photo op opportunities as well it's very
visual a lot of Inflatables or snow
everywhere we got music playing so it's
really an exciting experience and it's
actually a chance for families to come
down and take actually their Christmas
pictures we've had a lot of families in
the past come down dressed up in like
you know sand outfits or they're dressed
up in like pajamas that are all holiday
flavored so it's really kind of a fun
experience for them to come down and
just kind of fill their whole social
media platforms with all kinds of great
visuals for Christmas awesome Derek what
sounds like it's gonna be a great time
thank you so much for joining us this
morning again you guys can come on down
here now Thursday through Sunday but
starting the 19th it'll be open every
single day and something that's
different from a lot of the experiences
it's also going to be open on Christmas
Eve Christmas Day New Year's Eve and New
Year's Day and of course we got you
covered with the details about the
tickets on our website itnewsnow.com
coming up we're going to tell you a
little bit more about how you can get
those free tickets for your children as
well as later on we're going to be
talking to Sam himself but for now a lot
of presents experience at Tiffany
Village I'm Candace Charles 8 news now
looks pretty cool they still dial it up
this year I like it thanks Candace
appreciate it we'll catch up later on
waiting for the exclusive with Santa
Claus oh I know